Joe how many projects were you
considering when the opportunity for the
automatic hate came across your
quote-unquote desk or in your inbox I
mean this was the only one you know I'm
I'm an actor who auditions and gets work
sometimes so I auditioned for Justin's
movie and I was fortunate enough to to
get it but I wasn't down you know
considering a whole slew of projects I
would love to be at some point I guess
that's interesting because because
people probably don't have that
perception of you but but so there's a
lot of waiting time I know in most
actors careers but you've also been
acting for 20 years like yours you're so
young and that's great that you have
that body of work no it's funny I think
that it's a misconception that people
think that actors are working all the
time or have offers on a ton of projects
but I've talked to some some really
famous actors who you would think would
work all the time and a lot of them are
struggling to find work and whether
that's because I think a lot of it's
because they want to do quality work you
know and find quality scripts and great
directors and that takes takes time
there's only so many well-made movies
every year and then there's only so many
parts for that specific actor so yeah I
think it's kind of a common
misconception that people have that but
like if you have worked you must be
offered a million different jobs you
must have a lot of different
opportunities but it's it's a it's a
hustle at every level I think
interesting yeah so I think that's
that's something that I wouldn't have
thought the answer would be that's
interesting to me um in general then
going back to this how many projects are
you usually considering at one time or
it sounds like maybe then there's long
delays no I'm you know I'm auditioning
I'm a working actor that auditions for
projects to try to get roles it's not a
I'm not
you know I'm not considering a bunch of
different projects any time I'm driving
around La in my Honda Accord signing my
name on sign-in sheets and auditioning
for people so Wow okay that's the truth
do you think sometimes that
misconception hurts you and that people
may be hesitant to contact you because
they'd love to have you in an indie film
but maybe it's it's you know a
low-budget feature or something and they
just think oh well he's going to be too
busy but it's really quality production
and in the storyline is very depth no D
I don't think so I mean I'm sure that
there's stuff that my my agent will
filter out maybe I don't even really
know I haven't ever asked her really but
I think that I think that anything
that's of a high quality will the cream
rises you know so I think that if you've
got a great script with a really
talented filmmaker if it's a small
budget I think you'll still get great
actors because people want to do good
work just switching gears a little bit
so when you're developing a character
let's say you have a little bit of a
composite of who they are
um what are you doing to ask yourself
about the story and about who the person
is trying to figure dig into what's
there for Davis and you know I knew that
he was college-educated and came from a
well-to-do Boston family highly educated
parents working in academia but he's
chosen to become a chef much to the
dismay of his father so that was sort of
a beginning kind of a thread that I
could pull the unravel his who he is you
know he's he's clearly thoughtful and
bright but he also has a bit of a
rebellious streak in him and I think
it's maybe a little bit more tactile
than his is more intellectual parents
aside from her beauty why do you think
Davis that's the character you play is
so drawn to Alexis
I think that he's drawn to her carefree
lifestyle and I think that well I think
first of all he's very curious about
this mystery in his life does he have an
uncle
does he have cousins that have been kept
from him his whole life and if so then
why so I think that that is something
that he's very curious about so I think
that he follows her to figure to figure
out that but then also becomes very
attracted to her and I think that aside
from her beauty he's attracted to her
way of conducting herself in the world
which is she very much to the beat of
her own drum and I think that something
that Davis struggles with in his real
life is the societal constrictions that
we all have to agree to to live in
civilization that you don't have to
agree to as much if you're living out in
the woods sure and I think in different
families too there's different pressure
oh absolutely yeah yeah you know if you
come from a from a very successful both
of his parents are very successful
psychiatrists and professors so I think
that there is that burden you know to
rise to that while I think that it's
interesting that he takes an entirely
different route by going into the
culinary arts right and at one point
it's referred to as oh you're gonna do
that cooking thing right his father so
dismissive I know well that's a Richard
Schiff improvisation I'll have you know
so he was getting into it
yeah I think that he's very dismissive
of that as a lesser profession which is
not how Davis feel something Davis
finds it meditative and and and it's
really interesting I mean I got to spend
some time in the kitchen with Johnny and
Phil who run Nicoletta's which is the
restaurant that we shot in for the film
so on the weekends they would let me
just come and hang out as they were
cooking and it is this sort of it does
have this meditative feel to it you know
it's it's hectic but they're just kind
of in the zone out of their heads
getting their food out it was fun I
completely understand why he would be
drawn to something like that and at the
same time they need to be on point about
so many things very organized
hmm and Phil owns the restaurant - so
he's key cooks and he owns it Wow so do
you normally do that for a lot of roles
kind of really immerse yourself into
that world if I can yeah I mean I think
that it just helps so much it's so scary
every time you decide to take on a movie
and a part and you want to do right by
the filmmaker and writers and everybody
else who's you know the producers put so
much work into it up into up until that
point and so I think that by trying to
sort of immerse yourself as much as you
can and the life that that character is
leading you get little clues from doing
that and it can kind of help guide you
to figure out who this this person is I
can I find it really helpful but some
people don't you know some people just
don't believe in any of that any of that
but for me it's it's it's so you want
for me I want something that I can kind
of summon concrete that I can understand
about the character that I can fall back
on in a moment of of uncertainty I think
you said in a prior interview Joe that
sometimes Justin would scrap a scene if
it wasn't working mmm and just let's
start from scratch so how do you regroup
after that I mean that's great if it's
not working why why keep going with it
yet you know Justin I did a lot of
talking about the script before we got
on set so that once we got on set we
could just go which is the way that I
prefer to work in the way that Justin
prefers to work so you know any
questions you have get them out before
so that once you're on set you can just
be you know in the moment and
comfortable that the scenes gonna work
but there was one scene on our last day
the scene where where Davis and Alexis
first meet it just didn't have it almost
like didn't have an end and now Adelaide
and I had both auditioned with that
scene so we never even really discussed
it before we got to said it was one of
those ones that we just kind of figured
would work because we'd both audition
with it and it worked in the room but
for some reason once we got on the set
it just wasn't really working and we
shot the master and then Justin Kamath's
me was like this isn't working I was
like I know what do we do and he said
you need to tell her to leave you need
to just say to her you know you freaked
out you don't know what's going on she's
got to get out of there and that's what
worked you know to to to bring the scene
to an end to add that bit of conflict to
get her out of there and so we actually
shot a different version of the scene
for the rest of the coverage which is
cool it's a testament to Justin's uh
adaptability is that something that you
normally experienced as a director will
kind of ask for your input or also just
when you all have a gut feeling like
this isn't working let's just say it you
know yeah usually yeah usually um that's
a touchy thing sometimes you don't wanna
overstep the balance but it sounds like
we know yeah I certainly don't want to
overstep my my bounds although I
probably do it all the time because if
so you know if you're feeling that it's
not working you have to it is my job to
say something and if I think that
there's a way to make the scene better
than I it would be a shame to miss that
opportunity so
I mean I don't I don't want to say it's
unique I think that it's pretty common
with filmmakers who know that there's
that there's that x-factor there's only
so much that you can plan for you can
have your absolute best script that you
can have you can't the best casting you
can have and everybody can be on the
same page and once you get the scene up
and on its feet it can become something
entirely differently you know entirely
different or it can pull one way or the
other way and I think that uh some of
the filmmakers that I've really enjoyed
working with like to go with that and
and feed that like elasticity I'm just
wondering if there's anything that
you're grappling with right now that
maybe you can put out to our audience to
that might be in terms of acting whether
it's booking roles finding meaningful
roles that really love time management
anything finding good work yeah it's not
it's just not that easy there's not a
lot of great films that get made every
year and of the films that are really
good that are made there's only so many
parts for somebody like myself so I'm
just constantly looking for good
filmmakers who will have me on their
sets and I've been pretty fortunate so
far but there are there are long periods
of time that you don't work for and you
start to get depressed and you start to
question what you're doing and question
your ability and and I oh it always
happens for me in the absolute lowest
moment that I'll get a good job you know
when like all hope is lost
is when you know I'll end up getting to
work with one of these great filmmakers
so I've been fortunate enough to work to
work with and it is there's just a daily
grind to to trying to be an actor it's
just a you know it's I think it's
something that a lot of people want to
do
so you know it's it's a it's a hustle
but um high highs and low lows and those
highs make it all worth it right there
are certain things you do to keep
yourself high or do you almost enjoy
because I know some people really almost
enjoy the the low because the high is so
great or it also keeps them it kind of
gives them material for or a mindset
that they can tap into later well yeah
that's so true it's those lower points
you know where your money's running out
and you're not getting to do the
creative art form that you love that
keeps you satisfied those darker moments
probably do inform the work in it in in
a really great way but that being said
but I give them up for more opportunity
probably yeah
and you know I've got just really
wonderful group people around me you
know so so that's nice obviously to have
good friends and close family to kind of
keep your your spirits up what are some
of the things you do to keep do you go
see other films you read do you like to
read a lot I read a lot like OC films
I'm married now we have a dog oh not
really an activity but yeah try to
travel a little bit around California I
really like going up and down up the
coast yeah and then and then there is
the day-to-day of reading scripts and
deciding whether or not it's something
that you want to to chase after and
that's sort of you have to always be
ready for that because you know it could
be two weeks where nothing's happened
and all of a sudden you look at your
phone and tomorrow you have to audition
for some iconic filmmaker and you just
have to be ready to do that
do you find that getting out of LA you
talked about a road
Broner really kind of helps you put
things in perspective because in this
little microcosm here everybody's so
focused about yes thing that's in front
of them getting out of La really helps
me to clear my head and also I think
that being from New York there's this
this sort of misconception that people
have where they say okay I'll go to LA
for you know three weeks and if I get
something I'll stay that's just really
not the way that it works it's a war of
attrition it's you got to dig in and and
commit to where you're gonna be whether
it's LA or New York and I've gone back
and forth between the two a lot but I'm
enjoying it here and I now have really
good friends here who also summer actors
a couple are actors and they were very
supportive of each other in that in the
struggle that is trying to find good
work in good projects any apps or
technology just switching gears a little
bit that you use that help organize your
day or that you can't live without that
are pretty technologically illiterate
I mean I'll I have to make audition tape
sometimes so I have to figure out it get
the tape from the camera to the computer
and send it out which was like big for
me to be able to figure that out I
really don't like yeah I don't have any
social media tools or any thing like
that I've read the news read the New
York Times and The Huffington Post
sometimes but I know those apps I guess
on my phone I use do you feel pressure
to be on social media no no I mean I
don't look you know I know that people
can't there's a their studio movies that
are casting that are they'll you know
look at your Twitter followers before
they look at your tape you know and I
totally get that and that there's
nothing wrong with that
to me but it's just not it's just not
the way that I'm interested in being
caste so it's it's also not that
something I'd be good at I don't think
I'd be good at garnering a following of
people by tweeting out what I thought
that morning it's just not for me you
know so no I've never felt no one's ever
said to me like you know maybe Justin it
would be easier if I was really wrong
with what oh yeah sure there's no but
I've heard stories of you know producers
sitting in a room with headshots and the
number of Twitter followers underneath
and deciding like okay you know the
director really wants the actress with
you know 1.2 million Twitter followers
but the studio really wants the actress
but the three and a half million Twitter
followers and where we can a settle its
you know and what's funny is the movie
that I'm thinking of it was a complete
disaster when you'd never even heard of
it and it was a huge movie and I was a
friend of mine who worked on it and he
was just watching this process and just
thinking like this has got to be a
recipe for disaster so it's not a rat
race that I think I would be any good at
so I'm not interested and lastly what
what are you reading not what are you
wearing what are you wearing Levi's
everything I think I read a lot of
nonfiction
I've been reading mostly I've been on a
pretty big tear of reading books about
the our two most recent wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan and learning a little about
a little bit about the people of those
countries and what led to our country
doing what it did what led to what
happened to our country that led to
those things and she's trying to
understand
understand what happened understand the
toll that it's taken that I don't think
that people really understand I mean
because it's not because it's no longer
a draft our lives aren't affected in the
way that the lives of the families
specifically in places like Kansas and
Nebraska or lower-income communities
throughout the country where a lot of
people are recruited from it's taken a
very heavy toll and people have come
back from these wars struggling and it's
really not something that I think is
being addressed to the extent that it
should be and I think that so that's
something that really interests me the
prison system is something that really
interested me going from the you know
starting with the war on drugs going
from the war on poverty to the war on
drugs and then this world of mass
incarceration that we're living in
that's very racially imbalanced and so
that is something that I've been
interested in for a while so I'll read
that sort of stuff
just light reading you know whatever I
can pick up at an airport no so those
are two topics that have been recurring
for me for whatever reason when I go
into a bookstore it just seems to be
what I'm I'm drawn to there's a great
book called the new Jim Crow that's
about about the prison population and
there's a couple really great
Iraq war books that I can tell you about
later if you want it but well do you
think you'll ever write a part for
yourself in a story about that since it
sounds like that's what you're drawn to
instead of something but maybe the heavy
a topic for a lot of people it's a heavy
topic it's not something that's been
explored the way it was after Vietnam
because of course Vietnam was the draft
you know so everybody was being affected
and and and and the president's hands
weren't as free as you are with a with
an all-volunteer army because you have
to answer to all these people who don't
want to go to war as opposed to people
who theoretically do you want to go to
war I guess if you join the military
that's a different thing but but will I
ever write myself apart you know I'm I'm
not a great writer and I've worked with
some really great writers and I've tried
my hand at it and maybe it's something
that as I get older I'll get better at
but I've got such tremendous respect for
the screenwriters that I've worked with
that I kind of tend to stay in my lane
just because you know and the great
filmmakers I've gotten to work with it's
not I'm an actor you know and I want to
be an actor and that's kind of the top
priority for me so I would love somebody
else to write that script rather than
it's something I'm very interested and
it's it's it's a topic that movies are
are starting to explore people returning
from war but almost in like a not fully
like a you know you'll have a movie that
maybe has a returning War veteran but
it's also it's often very contrived and
sort of stereotypical and I don't think
we've had a story like Hal Ashby is
coming home or like the deer hunter yet
deer hunter
so we'll see we'll see if anybody starts
making these movies I'm interested to go
see them I don't know if they'll
necessarily make as much money as
they'll cost and so that's always what
you know by people to make movies so
you'll see a lot of foreign films though
I think or foreign films yeah thinking
because it's less I say this yeah
there's less bring them home you know
there's less that attitude well also the
you know like there's their film
Commission's in other countries so you
know Ireland or Denmark or Australia has
a Film Commission so you can take a film
that isn't maybe so commercial and get
government support because it has a
message that a committee I guess
determines matters so I think that that
helps a lot in in those foreign films is
a really beautiful I believe it's a
Danish film called a war they came out
this year yeah love it great movie do
you see anything yeah so good amazing
yeah and I wondered if it wasn't made in
Denmark if it was made here how it would
be received you know yeah and what did
it cost I wonder and what is it made and
write all those things that you know the
questions that people ask before they
make movies well one last thing just
wrapping up I know Sebastian Junger has
talked about mm-hmm
men and women comes look at his work
yeah right from combat any talks I own
one of this photography books yeah he's
a he's amazing and and he had a doctor's
rendering area too aside from he had
Restrepo and I forgive me the other one
is is I'm drawing a blank on the name
but in it he talks about people
returning from war and their levels
being blown out because they're so used
to being under like high stress and that
nothing is ever really the same so
taking that same analogy when you work
on something that's so like you just
feel like this adrenaline kind of
pumping and then you have to go back to
sort of normal life do you ever feel
sometimes like your levels or maybe
blown out because totally I mean nothing
compared to people in war yeah but there
is when you work on a film there is
there's a community that you develop you
know you become very close you become a
family get to know people very
intimately and they become your close
friends that you're seeing every day
and you are full speed ahead working to
make this project the absolute best
version of itself you know the best that
it can be so there is definitely a funny
comedown period after and I have to be
careful about easing myself back in so
but it's you know I I think it was a
much harder when I was younger
especially when I was but I was working
when I was a child and I was a kid so I
would go off and get to be around adults
all the time and have like three hours
of onset tutoring rather than a whole
day of school and I got to work which is
what I love to do you know I've really
enjoyed acting from when I was from when
I was a kid that's why I did it it's
where my parents supported me in doing
it and so to go back to school in my
suburban town wasn't quite the same so
that was it was a big culture shock when
I was younger
but now that I've got a community of
people in film around me that understand
it's easier to come back to